tell us a bit about storage 24 and what
we can look forward to when it comes out
okay storage 24 it's very it's a it's a
group of people that are trapped in a
storage facility like like these big
yellows that you get and their plane
crashes has kind of locked down London
and there's a mysterious cargo that's
been on the plane and the car goes that
is an alien that has I won't go too much
into that but it gets into the storage
facility and these guys can't get out of
the storage facility and they're up
against this creature and it's there
like that
it's very scary and it's quite gory as
well but really what I did with this
which I hope really translates your
audiences is the alien is a character
and I don't think we've seen that for a
long time you know it's usually
everybody's always about keep the alien
in the dark don't see too much of what
you see don't show too much keep it in
the shadows and I really just thought no
I want to see this thing and so I've
really bought it out there and it's it
talks it communicates it it doesn't
understand its world and it's a bit real
humor there and it and it it kills
because it's pulling these people apart
and doesn't really get why they're
forming apart so it's very funny and it
in a very dark way this is your first
sci-fi movie really isn't it because
you've really specialized in horror
before haven't you have you found that
change yeah it's been fun in the sense
although it's science fiction it owes a
lot a tease monster movies and a lot to
kind of stuff like gremlins and you know
sort of fades it has a very retro feel
so actually the jump hasn't been too bad
but yeah I think the two genres are very
interchangeable you know aliens alien
the thing you know there's science
fiction movies but they're Horrors and
that's kind of what I grew up on so yeah
it's been fun what was the film that
made the difference for you picking up a
camera to become a filmmaker the film
that made me want to get into filmmaking
mr. film called Cujo which had a kill a
rabid dog and the Stephen King thing and
I really just suddenly saw
the fun you could have as a director
trying to scare people and what you
could do with the camera and then
through Stephen King I then discovered
John Carpenter first of all Christine
and then you know just just all the
classics the thing and all that kind of
stuff and just really you know so I just
a lot of carpenter and King as I grew up
really what particularly grabs you about
these two genres and horror and sci-fi
what particularly appeals to you about
them no I think to be scared I you know
I go I've not been scared in a movie for
a long time but occasionally you you you
find a movie and and it really does
scale it the orphan angel the gradual
the ring recently did that to me and I
just it's such a pure emotion and it's
such a wonderful emotion it's so it's a
crazy thing cuz it's such a negative
emotion fear but you're in a you know
that is only temporary it's just yeah
it's an incredible thing to feel that
adrenaline and to try and recreate that
for an audience is a great thing I think
I think you just have the ability to to
explore themes as well you know with
genres that you can't do in drama or
anything else thinking about fear there
wondering is it something that you have
to live with in a sense as a filmmaker
as well excuse my language but yes yeah
I mean you're constantly terrified at
least with horror at least we're
watching our movie you know after 90
minutes it ends but yeah with a
filmmaker the you never know when the
next paychecks coming in or whether
anybody likes your movies or you know
it's a constant sense of fear you're
talking this on the panel this afternoon
about the state of filmmaking in general
and in particular I suppose for sci-fi
given it the work the sci-fi London
Festival in the UK at the moment can you
tell us a little bit more about that
what your feelings are on the state of
sci-fi yeah it's an interesting thing I
mean to do a UK science fiction movie
has been quite I think it's quite
unusual I don't think there's that many
you know we do quite a lot of Horrors
now but science fiction
I was very nature
needs more money I think it's very
tricky in this country to do that kind
of movie because you're up against
Hollywood which is doing it and science
fiction is the kind of by and large it's
a genre that is about money and you know
recently lock-out just came out the Guy
Pearce movie which is a European base
and that had some money behind it but it
didn't have enough money and it just
died you know compared to American
filmmaking
you know like battleship not seen it but
you know that's they've put some serious
money behind it so that's a very tricky
thing is to try and reinvent the genre
so it doesn't involve money
so monsters is a great example of that
is to do science fiction movie in a way
that you don't notice they the filmmaker
doesn't have a lot of money
you